how many people here are still in
college
you guys are the dumbest people in
America nobody tells you this that's the
problem and you're like I'm at an
institution of Higher Learning you're at
a daycare for 18 to 22 year olds you
remember how parents during covet were
like I'm so over this that's
your parents for 18 years so they're
like look we'll take out a loan from
some mafioso named Sallie Mae and
you're like no dude like like understand
the world now you understand nothing you
understand your College bubble you know
you can go out tonight and have sex with
a girl wearing sweatpants that's not
happening after 22
hopefully he can dance why don't you
dance your way to a job interview how
about that
man I wish I could watch when you guys
turned 28 and start looking at the
amount of taxes they're taking out and
they're like you know what let's move
this ballot to the right that's gonna be
so
funny to watch